so let's talk traffic and more Tropicana
it's a big big deal what they're doing
this weekend Nate Tannenbaum is live
right above the project site this
morning to talk about all the big
closures this weekend Nate good morning
to you sir
good morning John so that back at the
you're talking about happening live
right now South under the 15 at Flamingo
that is going to be close that's where
the southbound lanes and the 15 are
closed the Northbound Lanes will be
closing at Russell Road that's so that
the Tropicana project can take down the
Tropicana bridge over the I-15 because
it was built in the 1960s it was widened
in the 1990s and the project manager
Lynette Russell joins us here this
morning Lynette this is a huge deal to
widen Tropicana but it may be painful
for the drivers this weekend it it might
be a little painful this weekend as we
Route traffic along our surface streets
Russell Decatur and Flamingo while we
have I-15 closed they're going to be a
lot of detour signs there's hopefully
people will follow along but you and I
were just talking moments ago with
Armando here and maybe our drone the
reconfigured Tropicana when it opens on
Monday will have something called a
diverging diamond can you explain that
real briefly I sure can yeah so we
already have a diverging diamond in town
here that people may not know about up
in Horizon Ridge the diverging diamond
will take people on the opposite side of
the road which sounds a little scary
maybe it works really well for traffic
flows makes it a lot easier for people
to get use these off-ramps and on-ramps
yeah so that's the deal so back here
live we're talking about how the
Tropicana when it reopens on Monday will
be looking a little bit differently but
the big story is the closure of the
freeway and Armando I want the viewers
to know that Lynette was kind enough to
make a bow tie for me with the Tropicana
logo on it Lynette I cannot thank you
enough that is so nice of you to do that
and stay with eight news now throughout
the weekend for ongoing reports about
the closure of the I-15 10 o'clock
tonight till 5 Monday morning between
Flamingo and Russell both directions
follow the detours tell your friends
John and tell the trucking industry how
it works huh yeah exactly and we can and
you can tell people all day long with
your bow tie just say by the way look at
my neck watch out this weekend thanks
Nate appreciate it 6 35 so as we
discussed closing I-15 can be a major
setback for all drivers but especially
for truckers they've got to get things
where they need to go the Nevada
Trucking Association says drivers though
are prepared it's worked with ndot to
figure out alternate routes to keep
everybody on schedule now the CEO of the
association couldn't confirm that there
will be an impact but he does say that
you know drivers are used to adapting to
these kind of situations
we appreciate that there's going to be
some investment to make it better to
make it flow a little easier than it
does today but we understand that yeah
you do have to adjust your operations
and uh get around that construction
once again I-15 closed in both
directions from Flamingo down to Russell
starts tonight and goes until Monday
morning